and this video contains spoilers for
people who haven't seen The Avengers
movie if you haven't seen it yet though
keep watching you deserve these spoilers
that's right we're gonna talk about this
agents of shield TV show I'm not saying
Asians of shield I'm saying agents of
shield
I'm not raisin people always think I say
Asians when I say agents and there's
just not accurate folks it's not unless
they're an Asian agent in which case I
guess so among the whole Avengers movie
thing we heard that there was gonna be a
TV show produced by Joss Whedon in which
it follows the organization shield we're
all like that's probably gonna be cool
because Joss Whedon and TV shows have
always made cool before now we have like
a 30-second TV spot in which case I
still know nothing about it however one
thing is clear friends Coulson lamps
Agent Coulson is in this TV show and
people are like how is that happening
because it takes place before the
Avengers but the diabolical they of the
studio are like no this takes place
after the movie the Avengers I don't
know how Coulson's in it is the Avengers
there could be a myriad of raises could
be magic he could be at another agent
coulson he could be a drone clone Agent
Coulson robot from the future sent back
in time in which we've all been targeted
for Coulson ation as sounded dirtier out
loud who did in my head point is Coulson
is back and that's awesome because
everyone loves Agent Coulson and this
also tells me this one thing will
doesn't tell me just this one thing but
it does tell me one thing in particular
all right so wash is totally dead but
now we know he doesn't have to be not if
Joss Whedon is the producer he doesn't
just Whedon is notorious for killing
characters that you like I like the fact
now he's like well I never want to take
that one back because I'm Joss Whedon
and I have an awesome beard and as cool
as this concept is it's gonna deal with
super-powered dudes and jacks and you're
like I hope doesn't go the hero's wrong
people have asked me to do a review on
heroes it is simply this season one was
awesome and that is where I end that it
shield the agents of shield have a lot
to do there are a lot of agents of
shield seriously just look at HeroClix
I'm not even lying I started HeroClix
last week look at me now it's a sickness
there are a lot of characters that are
involved with shield so I'm looking
forward to this again I hope it's not
that thing that holds the whole Avengers
thing back but I really think if Joss
Whedon is involved in this series it
could be awesome and it would be really
cool to see how the TV show ties into
phase 2 and phase 3 of The Avengers I
hope it's not what holds it back and
makes it
that would be terrible so far everything
that's been involved in leading up to
the Avengers has been really cool I
would hate to see a TV show produced by
Joss Whedon to be the thing that's like
yeah we wish that never happened
break my heart I don't know we won't
know until we see it the only thing I've
seen now is this TV spot that it just
ain't that long but it doesn't mean I'm
not gonna make a video about it I guess
they're really going good I don't want
their egos to feel like we can do
anything then they make a TV show that
ties in with everything that's not that
good I'm really cautiously optimistic I
want anything involved with The Avengers
to be good but I'm really optimistic for
how cautious I am I'm like yeah
cautiously optimistic that being said
yeah it's kind of like that this is
what's going on in here so agents of
shield and the fact that Coulson lives
and that's a hashtag I guess I guess the
hashtag of the whole thing is Coulson
lives cuz he does and now we know a god
cannot kill Coulson yes sorry Loki you
may be the god of mischief but one does
not simply kill the Lord by stabbing him
in the back and now you know that so
agents of shield are you looking forward
to it do you think it's gonna be a
really good standalone kind of thing do
you think it'll be good for the Avengers
movies to tie in with it do you think
it'll hold The Avengers 2 back if it
ties in with it too much
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]